at all levels will have been deeply
affected by this mindless act and i'm
sure members you would join me with the
residence of the district to spend a
moment of silence to remember him and
his family to whom we send our deepest
sympathies
one minute silence i'm standing
thank you members so returning to this
point of order business member points of
order if you wish to speak points of
order
morris your behavior is unacceptable
point of order
point of all your behaviors are
acceptable because you're supposed to
listen to these two appointments
no i won't seize this fight
you have no authority
on me you have no authority over me do
you mark and the know the points of all
god
of
if at any meeting points account
the business of the council points of
order
may move a point of that
aimed not to be further heard and the
motion decisions let's see our foreign
would you like to see the what's that
message
now then too
i've got a point of order are you going
to listen to it
i'm not doing your sums for you michael
i know that you i know that you're a
little bit you know stumped by that
continuing points of control conduct
point of view
of older
right for a diet coke
yeah it's ridiculous isn't it
just as ridiculous as you're having the
three monkeys that where you couldn't
see no people hear no evil and no no
evil when you were sitting right next to
the guy when he was pulling his finger
across right members
so just as ridiculous as that we are at
the situation that i went of order i
have to look at the duty of care to
point out hold up towards those members
of the staff point of uh order i have to
say that uh
oh you are living in all the world of
insults allegations
order uh the standards committee point
out you to bob
and a bully and right straight evidence
that lie evidence that i'm a liar
evidence that i'm a liar and the next
copper oh yeah so you're the coward you
won't even answer a
watched homophobic bullying go on and
said nothing you're not you sat there
and watched homophobic bullying going on
no breaking going on and you came here
oh there was no bullying going on so
yeah come closer please i want everyone
to listen to this
democratically let's just get this
sorry guys could you just identify
yourselves please yeah please
please
right first time to begin with um
because i'm democratically elected i'm
allowed to speak
yeah you're not allowed to speak
you are not allowed to speak because you
have not been heard
but this time
um you're essentially preaching the
peace no no i'm not allowed i'm not
no i'm asking no
excuse me excuse me we're doing well
please no i'm not no i'm not
interrupting because
i've been summonsed here i am legally
entitled to be who are not right legally
entitled
i
i'm not reaching the peace because i am
democratically elected to represent okay
i still want to continue this meeting
i'll check this out yeah you guys
shouldn't be getting involved a gender
item three are declarations of interest
this is to disclose the existence and
nature of any disposal non-continuing
interests
relating
members are reminded that they are also
required to dispose of any such
interests as soon as they become aware
should they need
throughout the meeting do i have any
declarations of interest yeah councillor
point of order thank you chairman uh
non-punery interest that's a member of a
point of order i'm sorry chairman the
point
i have i
chairman i'm also a member of essex
county council nonprofits
thank you very much tell me what part of
the constitution i think so
all right okay uh how about yeah the
gender item for it is recommended the
minutes of the statutory annual council
meeting yeah found on pages 5 to 15 are
approved
down
i will do it page by page thank you can
i just confirm tara that you are still
looking at this uh remotely
yes okay thank you very much
okay if i stop talking to you so it will
be page five
what i want to do is page six trophies
all i want to do is speak page seven
page eight nine hey jay
no thank you chairman if i may
and chairman it was rather disappointing
that um having highlighted the name of
an officer for their work point of
volder leonie alpin
um i know that the minutes aren't meant
to be verbatim but i do think because i
did acknowledge the good work and so did
the council
but when the name of an officer is
stated by a member in the chamber that
that name should be reflected in the
minutes and i would like to see yelp his
name acknowledged in that minute
chairman thank you very much
thank you very much
section please i'm going to uh an
appointment will go past the uh
he's got no right to speak here
i have every right to speak here i've
been elected i've been elected
this is democracy you might not like me
but you've got to listen to me
we do not have to listen to you we have
made we have you don't listen to anyone
mark do you i'll move to
committee held in this chamber on the
6th of september
2021
found on pages 17-21 just being placed
and proposed their reception do i have a
secondary
councilman
thank you
i give you page 17 page 18
age 19. yeah i'm age 20.
and the committee decision
and i put the recommendation at little
form
that counselor chrissy morris be removed
from all committees including planning
committees district planning working
groups and outside bodies for the
remainder of the municipal year 2021 to
2022
to the council for approval
i so move
do i have a secondary
council
thank you very much now i have several
hands here councillor laggard trust now
thank you
all right
you've been in distress
because i'm not going to allow bullying
thank you chair um
i uh i'm not that distressed i watched
the jsc and read the various papers and
all i'm interested in is talking about
the agenda paper this evening yeah and i
feel that very much so that there's a uh
this recommendation for these sanctions
against council morris are actually
incorrect the uh the previous uh
sanctions that were levied against
another councillor who brought the
council on themselves into disrespect
was
significantly longer and for consistency
okay
and to ensure that this council acts
consistently and openly i move that we
amend the emotion so that councilor
morris although he doesn't sit on
anything um is for a duration of 12
months and not to the end of the
municipal year
thank you
so that is an amendment councillor
councillor helm
thank you mr chairman as you know i set
on the previous jsc committee where uh
councillor morris was found not guilty
um
and also set on the one that counts
concern another councillor he would yes
he was given a 12 month ban but it was
in between terms so in actual effect he
had 18 months ban
so i move that should be an 18-month ban
can i have a second to please
so have we had ace
we
your
original proposal hasn't been seconded
yet council again no i'm prepared i'm
prepared
and it has been uh has been seconded
um could i have a vote on that please
members
we
and that will be an 18-month ban so can
i have a vote on that those recorded
vote
what
what and those again recorded vote for
each other what
did you give to the 18 months
it made
so those in favor please show recorded
vote
and those against please show
none that is carried
can i just ask what does it matter
i'm not on any committees i don't want
to be on any committees i'm here to
expose the corruption that's here there
is no corruption here yes there is
there's loads you've acted this council
has acted unlawfully
twice in two years
substantive motion now that that
proposal has been caught we now have a
distracted motion
um of our council morris been removed
from all committees um and that's
included with district planning
um and the area planning committees so
it's all committees working groups and
outside bodies up until may 2023 as a
result of that vote just taken that is
now the substantive motion chairman and
i so propose
is that seconded
i'll second it and is that agreed i'll
second it
raise your hands please anybody again
vote
recorded votes
well he's not even he's never been
asking for a second or is he
guys i'm not even on any of the
committees
this council has acted unlawfully
twice in two years unlawfully
nothing gets done about it it's not how
much money are we paying
former staff members
to
to to keep quiet about criminal
activities here are you happy to move
how comes
we've played another thank you very
former staff member
to um to keep quiet about criminal
activity at this council
i feel that this is an appropriate time
to have a five minute adjournment
that's what we'll do i'd like the uh i
like the
members happy with that okay
okay can we stop on a live streaming
please and we will have a five minute
adjournment thank you
we'll uh we will resume this this
meeting
point of order
you have been asked to leave this
meeting and i will not be leaving the
meeting it is my democratic right to sit
here and speak if you'd have allowed me
to speak at the start we wouldn't have
got
to
enough
and walk out in protest and i will close
the point of order
point of order
meeting is closed meetings closed
couldn't take a point of order again
you